Stab lab.
Now,
rod
gangster
got a stick on.
The Mama says she liked
to
the
Carl's cookie.
Tyler is saying girl,
cause
of the tattoos,
uh,
seen APP,
but she was pushing a stroller.
Smoke no cigarette during in a suit
lab.
Nanotube Bass and battery.
The soul
Betas name tattooed on his shoulder.
Devil.
She's
a
sad girl.
Does man,
when that group number tattooed,
see here,
sad guru living on the east side of the city.
I'll show the crowd
bag of Wilson.
Seen Ost office man.
Oh Shit.
She says daggone she never banned Solon alone.
No,
she got Megan
girl,
man grew up the tattoo to you.
You
Sag Guru.
He Sad Rau.
Wallman Bolshie Loughnane you know
Sag.
Who Gotten Rau?
Woman don't me.
Oh,
she'll grab
bag.
Most of me.
She's a Sagd girl cause man went away.
Now come in man.
Powerful.
It's so great to have you back,
man.
That was awesome.
Thank you sir.
Brian Belasco joining me.
Brian.